[Music]
one last time one last time the
microphone like old school everything is
like we used to be
god damn it's loud though shutting down
in 2020 this is the last chance last
time of playing happy wheels I didn't
think I was gonna be crying come on
nothing there that positioned let's go
let's play the highest rated of all time
guy incognita harpoon Dodge I forgot I
forgot the game stocks damn it damn it I
forgot that the game sex harpoon Dodge
you just lay down no wow I think I broke
my strings like a mouse did I make it I
think I'm still alive if you can pass
this level it means I'm god I got so
good all right let me just head down
there all right I'm gonna just head out
no I'm definitely dead all right
let's freakin do this I want my toes
there it is my toes can tank anything
I'm gonna have to sacrifice my don't
worry I can reattach the feet
damn that was good I'm actually like a
pouch all right if you pass this level
you are I got all right here we go that
was it
thanks for playing hope you like it have
a nice day I will have nice day
alright next level of course Spanish I
got clicky aqui para Senor for Senor air
some text only tallien I know apparently
well Jesus Christ did I was wonder if
the kid could drive the bike but I don't
think he can I pick Spanish but he still
still speaks English and the ammo but
being it oh come on dude I can't be
bothered of the interest too long
I have no attention span keeps asking
for I what's Spanish no what is this
what am I supposed to do Oh play
tic-tac-toe no way
that's that's kind of awesome
all right I got to get 5 cool oh well
now I got it I get four or five oh I can
get four no I'm just gonna aim for four
here okay fine now I'll get four damn it
now I'll get four
eight damn it I lose yes and then we go
for seven sweet perfect because now we
can just do this nice sweet sweet
victory drop it
this is why I love happy wheels Oh
oh I remember these don't fight to me
baby that's what babies get am i alive
[Music]
damn it Indy it keeps hitting my groin
what a weird coincidence
[Music]
[Laughter]
oops I'm having a bad day I'm definitely
not ah hey baby
[Music]
we're together now we're on this journey
together
[Music]
versus the backstory it's a human
centipede
it's alright we go together we're a team
alright guess not Jesus Christ a
metaphor how women sucking the life out
of you am i right gamers ah that's just
man
it looks like I have a big nothing
coming out oh she took it nice
what's parkour jump oh my god these oh
[Music]
Jesus
I'm dantdm that's cool wait that TDM is
better than me
I don't think so dantdm I could have
been ultimate pro hi I know this
strategy is to disembark and then
cannonball and then fly Hey all right I
win controllers [ __ ] oh I can shift them
that's really cool interesting Oh Merry
Christmas
and then that happen what is this lean
back haha bye [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's fun I like that met happy wheels
levels is like youtube.com/ is people
just copying the same concept over and
over and over this is my first level
good luck ok first level she says all
right we got speed son oh god damn it
really good for you oh hey pretty good
for first level not gonna lie
nose run Oh what in the world but why
put why is that a boob you guys like the
dinosaur Go Go game nah this is better
hey I did it except I'm Swedish thank
you
[Music]
I don't know if I'm amazed or sad but
someone spent time making that wait what
whoa there's car in happy wheels no
freakin way they throw cabbage in the
bucket to win okay why am I playing this
this is sad dude this apartment I'll go
without you you son of a punch look at
this [ __ ]
this how you ride a bike [ __ ]
yeah this is how you bike and Sweden
[ __ ] yeah yeah see I'm actually
really good at happy wheels a lot of
people don't know this front flip does
anyone even remember this has anyone
stuck with my channel oh oh hey I made
it
epic rope swings yes Rob swings were the
best you just grab on and then you go
and it's awesome there you go
what how do they do that I was supposed
to go down here nice
Oh found secret lair nice yeah give me a
back massage
come here Lake yes yes my sweet leg I
love you you are my queen I'm trying to
kiss you
oh yes yes happy at last
Oh a back massage ah oh yes let's just
bite the right there oh yeah yeah keep
scratching did anyone ever make a happy
will song cuz I mine all day I'm I know
no there we go got it
yeah yeah okay Oh God I don't think I
grabbed that or did I no I definitely
did not come back please wait I can
still do it oh I don't have enough
patience to play this games anymore
spike oh my god let's go like a Baus
complete this level like a bow yeah yes
okay son you try it out you test it out
you go good good luck sense disappoint
him here we go yeah for jacksepticeye
the best youtuber ever thank you what
I've never seen pixel art oh Jesus
Christ of course it can't touch the
beauty how do they make that
I'm so confused damn there's some
significant improvements it's almost sad
that it's gone down now like look at
that I became the slide itself it says a
lot about life wait oh I never played
this guy
all right well that worked out well okay
don't die don't die got it
okay we got to be this one don't die
come on let's go yeah yeah yeah I'm
still alive I'm still alive I'm still
alive I think I'm dead
alright here we go alright come on come
on shut god damn it you're so useless
all right you tanking I got it I got it
you gotta back up there it is
what's this yeah maybe this guy will do
it the answer is no okay
I get it I get it I get it now I get it
now yes yes I'm alive nevermind ooh
brain test brain dies then I pass the
brain test
that I just suck up a full woman nice
bow - yes come here nor suck you up I
like this I like this character I never
play us him rise and shine mr. Freeman
I'm not gonna read a story of someone
that doesn't matter kappa lice
i chapter 1 the forest okay here we go
stun yeah
all right level to God all right we got
a egg someone joined us
shut up sin shut you come on every day
oh no oh no well I was that death thrown
hard
sure sure buddy I can't
what does bottle flip again I forgot all
right
MLG oh my god I can be MLG guys so close
so close rate 5 to get so many people
fell for that hey at least I'm pro at
least some pro whoa I like that ah the
good old sword throws that one dude you
hate him I went for my mom instead
killer
kill her look off he'll see how could
you double sword yeah
Taco Bell employee gimme uncle Rick gets
spared I mean you get spared we hear you
cool ok cool survive if you can oh god
no on the table
I made it and my legs are made it to
come in Lake I love you I love you like
a son
yeah look at this bet you can't do this
yeah yeah oh they're coming back to me
ooh 50.9% impossible okay here we go I
see as absolute win all right let's do
that classic ones right Godwin the goat
what is that Dan that looks legit there
whoa what holy crap dude that's amazing
what people are still actually creative
this is beautiful how I get to I don't
know it's too hard for me I can't do
this how do I get past oh [ __ ] got it
oh I see what how do they make this this
is so awesome
this is like a whole new game hey pal of
mine doing me a favor and get a box and
shove it back all right
I pressed shift too many times Jesus
Christ did it yeah oh shoot a Goodwin
Fei be wanting some good exercise hop
aboard Wonder Wheel are we better hard
worker good for your lady
whoa oh I get it I get it
damn this is crazy how do they do this
what happened to happy wheels this is
not this makes no sense
all right now we pull it up
damn look at that look at that I got
after a million pogo jump defense and I
haven't been playing this that's crazy
am i doing anything
oh it says numbers isn't it okay three
four BAM just kind of low-key spooky in
here I gotta hurry up there we go this
is nuts
very cool what is that then combine and
then you have this oh yeah oh yeah
god dammit let me start at least here we
go
Jesus out of my way
thank you yeah
[Music]
it's said rate five if I made it so I
have to rate five there we go
papers please what how did they do that
okay what do we get he ordered Yakko
parodies now
Clara show Clara show how do I stamp it
granted nice that's so cool
denied glory to News Channel my old
channel was banned oh this is so sad
declined sure to shoot him he's escaping
thank you for flag glory tears does get
that's kind of cool
jacksepticeye spiky I already play this
watch me do it in the first try because
I'm jacksepticeye oh my god oh my god
well at least they know all right so
what's the most played level Pokemon
training apparently I choose to you
pokemon gym peek at you dan this is
nostalgic actually oh god playing these
ones feels like entering another time it
feels like a the Smosh era simpler times
you know I used to just like record
unedited happy wheels for like ten
minutes and that was an episode and
people loved it and I was all that was
necessary people just couldn't have
enough of happy wheels like it was just
that game to play and I mean I get it
it's a fun it's a fun game but then
people just for whatever reason made a
thousand episodes oh no his pedobear do
not want
Oh God oh Jesus look I wanna be the very
best like no one ever one to catch me in
my red did today and Amica look at that
that takes me back man
that takes me back I'm sorry there's
nothing we can do I always felt like
happy wheels had a lot of potential to
to be a lot bigger because it has such a
community behind it
wait this I want to say bridge okay
let's go wow I think the sad reality of
the fact is that the game just isn't
that fun anymore
that's right yeah I remember what my
favorite type of levels used to be
it was harpoon run yeah harpoon run Pro
my legs my legs now this is so sad rate
5 stars for my legs I can do it yeah you
know maybe it's not so bad that happy it
will just ice
on second thought ok actually then I
want to play
PewDiePie based levels ooh Peter pie
slend there oh my god this slender IRA -
yeah oh my god it's so scary
I'm scared oh god Dan this is legit dude
I haven't got one stop don't think so
there you go you're welcome hey I didn't
even get the soundtrack did
[Music]
[Applause]
no I think I died all right now we gotta
back up right it's crazy how much
YouTube has changed it used to just be
about who could find the newest crazy
game or whatever it wasn't really about
making good content sad really see
someone posted about slender on my my
forum it was like bro army net or
something like that and I saw that
actually no one had played the game and
he blew my mind cuz it looks so [ __ ]
scary dude
and I knew Slenderman was already a meme
on the Internet's I knew we would like
it would be huge thanks laying there man
and I remember like even when I played
happy wills people were like he
shouldn't play happy we should stick to
horror games imagine if I listened to
you guys
imagine wait welcome player welcome to
Peter Price adventure your mission is
finds to follow oh my god I got to fight
spider bro yeah hey don't you dare do
that again sorry bruh I gotta find
Stephano my number one bro are you just
threw that in my face goddamnit
alright you can kill my child but you
can't kill my spirit you okay back there
son I find Stephano come on where are
you
they are amazing yes stay there child
stay there I'm done with you oh no a
bear house and never decade huh
just hit me but you know there's gonna
be more severe house chair mode activate
[Laughter]
it's kind of cringe but also very
endearing and I like it
Peter pie run yeah yeah those children I
mean not literally okay here we go
come on yeah
[Music]
my son is disappointment that's it for
happy wheels hope you guys enjoyed smash
like so sad no more happy wheels I'm
crying on the inside
hey though hey
[Music]
the hour of fart smells in poop grades
is coming
marzia Edgar and buttons need you
[Music]
the timer you will face but crawlers is
all about
when you are seated on the porcelain
throne routine is the game to play I'm
not supposed to have my opinion about
that but the prizes
you